oh you can bring the witness in officer
thank you my precedent ladies and
gentlemen will proceed
with the direct examination
go ahead mr shelton
thank you
doctor just to finish up on the point
of the
sorry
okay
i heard my own voice there judge and i
i think it's okay now
are we good miss radler all right very
good please proceed mr shelton doctor
just one final question on the rorschach
you indicated that you had
reviewed dr hassan's
uh rescoring with the egzner what was
your impression of that restore
well the the um
again the the test is the the
it's invalid without a doubt but
um
there's some interesting points here
that seem to have been left out
for example if you look at page
[Music]
12 of 13
number 21
says here
this is from the i'm reading it now this
person meaning michael appears to be
excessively committed to seeing the
world accurately
he is consequently capable of perceiving
people and events realistically but he
is also likely to be the highly precise
impressions he forms of situations
only rarely we allow himself the risk of
forming an oppression that may be
inexact and then it goes down
to number 24 which i thought was
important generally speaking he displays
an adaptive capacity to think logically
and coherently
he is capable as most people have come
to reasonable conclusions about
relationships between events and
maintaining
a connected flow of associations which
ideas follow each other in a
comprehensible manner i think that's
important because that's the opposite of
a psychosis his thinking is clear and
logical based on this i don't know why
that was left out
and then it goes on the next page third
page 13 of 13.
i'm going down the third paragraph it
would start situation related stress
because he's consequently more
vulnerable than most people becoming
acutely upset anxious even disorganized
and a situationally determined stress
overload is also likely to appear as
capacity for self-control and create a
potential for impulsiveness in what he
thinks and says or does and then two
paragraphs down he displays an adaptive
capacity to think logically and
coherently
and the last sentence is there's a
connected flow of associations which
ideas
follow each other in a comprehensive
manner
this is all the opposite of a psychosis
why isn't that in a report why wouldn't
you
put that in come on
so i thought that was um noteworthy and
that's why i'm bringing it up and doctor
is that the riap
no that's the the rorschach
interpretation assistance program see
exner what he got from the expert judge
just so the record's clear that's
all right marcus
just going to ask you that question s435
okay
after moving on to the mmpi
could you generally explain what that
test is and what you're looking for sure
the mmpi it's the minnesota multiphasic
personality inventory test has been
around since the 1940s from the
university of minnesota that's why it's
called minnesota
personality inventory multiphasic just
means many different parts
the test has been around for years
and it has been re-standardized in the
early 90s by um a guy named james
butcher and james butcher is from the
university of minnesota so he's very
knowledgeable on this test he's really
the person who did the
re-standardization
i've used the mmpi for years and what i
use is
i use the 10 basic clinical scales 1
through 10 and 10 validity scales now
here's how the test is set up
before you interpret the profile the
test tells you how the subject was
taking the test
were they being
overly defensive
and denying problems that everybody has
such as never had a headache never had a
bad day true well that will elevate that
validity profile
are they over endorsing items to make
them appear more disturbed than they
actually are they have every symptom
bugs crawling up my skin uh hear voices
martians control my brain things like
that an over-endorsement
of items
or are they trying to
respond to items in a socially
appropriate fashion
um showing high moral values
and what's socially expected for example
before i vote in an election i
thoroughly investigate the candidate's
position on all of the issues true well
very few people do that but it's
socially appropriate so before you
interpret the 10 clinical scales you
look to see how the person was going
about taking the test and then you look
at the 10 clinical scales
very important
lecture number one
in the mmpi if you're teaching this
is the labels
of the 10 clinical scales should never
be taken literally it was never meant to
be that so for example if
if a person has a high elevation on
scale 4 the label is psychopathic
deviate that does not mean the person is
a psychopath it doesn't mean that
scale 8 is labeled schizophrenia if a
person has a high elevation on scale 8
it doesn't mean the person is
schizophrenic it never meant that
scale 6 for example is labeled paranoia
if you have a high elevation on scale
six that does not mean the person is
paranoid as a matter of fact most not
all but most flagrantly paranoid
individuals don't score high on that at
all
and if you look at butcher's
book i showed the prosecutor i don't
know if that any of that came out but
anyway he has a section that says
the literal interpretation do not
literally interpret these scale names
and the first sentence is if you do
you're poorly trained that's not me
that's butcher saying that so if you
think a high elevation on scale six
means you're paranoid it means one thing
according to butcher you're poorly
trained you don't understand what's
going on and if you read the description
from butcher on
on an elevation on scale six
it's nothing about delusions and and all
the rest of it so when i hear for
example in dr um hassan's report and i
i'm i do not want to be disrespectful at
all i'm trying my best not to be and i
don't want to be
but i but he said something to the
effect i don't know anybody
that would look at this high scale six
and interpret it anything different than
paranoid psychosis really i don't know
anybody that would including butcher who
wrote the book on it so it's just
incorrect now
when you gave this test to michael
barissone what were the results uh that
you came up with well i gave the test
the validity on page 53 if anybody's
following this the validity scales show
a non-significant exaggeration of
symptoms so that's not a problem there
was a slight attempt to give socially
approved answers
concerning self-control moral values but
it didn't invalidate the test sometimes
the validity scales are high and it
invalidates it that is not the case here
i found mild depression anxiety
suicide threats and attempts are
possible inner anger irritability
suspiciousness these are common symptoms
and individuals
likely control their anger but sometimes
they episodically explode and surprise
those around them now how am i getting
that it's not just scale six but he had
another scale elevation without getting
into the weeds high scale for low scale
five that's sometimes called a masculine
protest meaning individuals feel
insecure and try to
compensate for that by by demonstrating
that they're dominant in some way
also with the mmpi
what you do not do
or let me put it by the way what you do
do is you have to look at what's called
critical items
critical items are
what items is he responding to that's
elevating the scale this is common sense
and it really have to do it now i'm
looking at this is dr hassan's
findings and if you look at critical
items
let me show you these are the items that
elevated the scale that that michael
responded to also i should say this
before i even get into this
it is not at all uncommon for criminal
defendants pending a serious trial to
have a high elevation on scale six
because a lot of it is reality based
people are persecuting them and and out
to get them and talking about him so
here's the items that michael responded
to
doctor just before you judge this i
believe has been marked as s434 for
identification
all right and what is that exactly those
are scale scores no this is judge this
is the mmpi two
extended score report okay
and this is your understanding that dr
assange had
rescored
your scores or or used your scores and
and re-scored it
on his own oh yes but that's not the
point i'm making now i just wanted to
make the record clear yeah okay right
right right
go ahead
okay um so if you look at the critical
items now i did this and he did it too
how do i know it's right here
i am sure i get a raw deal from life
true
someone has it in for me true i believe
i'm being plotted against true i believe
i'm being followed true i feel i've
often be punished without cause true it
is safer to trust nobody true given
michael's situation now and the
circumstances you're in this is all
reality based
this is not a delusion or a psychosis
this is what he's experiencing right now
there's a there's a couple of other ones
someone has it in for me true i believe
i'm being plotted against true i believe
i'm being followed true i believe i'm
being talked about true
i have no enemies who really wish to
harm me false people say insulting and
vulgar things about me true every one of
these is reality based and so when you
get um
an mmpi you have to use your common
sense you don't throw your common sense
out and and and and not look at what he
responded to
that's what you have to do and when you
do it you see all of those are reality
based there is no basis at all to
conclude that the results of the mmpi
shows paranoid psychosis it does not it
absolutely does not
doctor you didn't uh render a diagnosis
based on your administering the mmpi or
the results you got from that test of
course not you never
no diagnosis from psychological tests
none
before i ask you about the two other two
tests that you gave doctor uh did you
also review dr hassan's or hassan's
excuse me uh results on the pai
yes
now
the the pai it's called the personality
assessment inventory this is a good test
now i mentioned the exeter bad test bad
scoring system rorschach good test but
the system is bad the mcmi the belong
clinical multi-axle inventory he also
gave which is a terrible test shouldn't
use but this is a good test the
personality assessment inventory i don't
know of any research article that said
otherwise um it's like the mmpi
basically uh a little shorter and um
it it's very good now when you look at
this test i think it's 17 pages long i'm
not 100 sure judge for the record uh the
doctor's referring to what's been marked
as
s436 thank you
all right thank you now you look at this
and and again
this on the cover sheet here says what
all of these say and i'm not just to
read the beginning it says interpret
information contained in this report
should be viewed only as one source of
hypotheses about the individual being
evaluated do you see that same in all of
these tests these are hypotheses
suggestions you don't make a diagnosis
based on a test but anyway when you look
at this test i open up the first page
and what do i see on the top
in bold capital letters warning
validity scales indicate hypotheses may
not be valid it doesn't say consider
this take a look at this by the way
bullet point no warning
and so this is on the top of the page
every page every single page of the 17
pages has it in bold print
in capital letters on the top warning
and then you go
to the actual um
uh validity scales because there's a
whole
validity of the test results now you
don't use any other validity
measures other than this validity
measure this is the validity measure
used by the test itself
so when you look at this and i'm on page
nine and doctor just to remind the jury
when you say the validity of the results
what does that mean it means the
validity of the results that they found
in this test warning it may not be
accurate so this is the test that was
given to michael barissone and the test
results indicate the validity is
questionable
more than questionable now when you put
warning on something that's to me that's
worth it quite insane results are
questionable take another look no they
said warning
and then they get into it on page nine
the last paragraph
the degree to which response styles may
have affected or distorted the report of
symptomatology on the inventories also
assessed it means they're doing this
certain of these indicators fall outside
the normal range suggesting that
the respondent may not have answered in
a completely forthright manner the
nature of his responses might lead the
evaluator to form a somewhat inaccurate
impression of the client based upon the
style of responding below
and then it goes on the next page and
again this is in capital letters
the test results potentially involve
considerable distortion and are unlikely
to be an accurate reflection of the
respondents objective clinical status
the following interpretation is provided
only as an indication of the
respondent's description
and then it goes on doctor in that same
paragraph is there anything in that
paragraph about malignant
um
well
yes
right above that it says with respect to
negative impression management
impression management
is a word means people try to manage
their impression to other people
patients do it
defendants do it all the time
negative impression management is you
want to appear more disturbed than you
actually are
positive impression management is you
want to appear less disturbed than you
actually are
so here
it says with respect to negative
impression management appearing more
disturbed
there are indications suggesting that
the client tended to portray himself in
an especially negative or pathological
manner
some deliberate distortion of the
clinical picture may be present
the critical item should be reviewed to
evaluate the possibility of malingering
and then it goes on
the important point is where is that in
his report i read his report and he said
the validity indicators are great and
here here we go that's not true i mean
come on now again i don't want to be
disrespectful and it's a little
uncomfortable doing it because someone
told me he's actually in in the
courtroom so i feel a little
uncomfortable doing it but uh anyway um
you know doctor let me let me ask you
you just used the term uh malinger in
there yeah can you tell the jury what
that term means and where it comes from
faking an illness it's as simple as that
a little boy doesn't want to go to
school because he didn't study for his
arithmetic tests tells his mother he has
a stomach ache a person with a mental
disorder wants to feign mental symptoms
for obvious legal
reasons and without jumping ahead too
far did you find evidence in this case
of malingering in the defendant's case
i didn't find any evidence of the
lingering
i didn't find any evidence of lingering
the doctor
son did but didn't report it as such let
me let me maybe let me ask the question
a little more pointedly did you find any
evidence of malignant amnesia oh
malingered amnesia yes yeah not
malignant yeah yes i found malignant
amnesia absolutely but not malingering a
mental disorder and can you explain the
difference between what you just uh
answered and what i had asked well
lingering generally means to malinger an
illness to maligner a disorder malignant
amnesia is different that's when you
claim you don't remember what had been
done but lingard amnesia um i mean i can
go into a lot of detail but yeah that's
that's
simply it can mean different things uh
in different situations
amnesia means simply it means only one
thing it means you're feigning loss of
memory that's what it means
doctor i want to direct your attention
at this point to some uh the last
two uh
tests that you gave to
michael barisson can you tell the jury
what the t-a-t is the t-a-t is the
thematic appreception test this is an
old test from the 1930s it shows
pictures of all sorts of
people in in ambiguous situations
and your job is to create a story and in
the process of the story
hopefully you'll reveal yourself and
more information about you will emerge
just give me a second
there is some water
it should be fresh too if you need it no
i'm fine
um
i give the tit tik is not scored this is
a projective test
and you you you interpret it at the
level of face validity face validity
means on the face of it can you see can
you understand what's going on within
the person so for example if a patient
says there's a person leaning over a
couch crying thinking of suicide her
life is terrible this is the end
you got a good idea of what's coming
from the person's mind you don't need a
score for that a scoring system at all
so i gave uh michael that test and he
gave ref he gave themes involving
depression despair
loss of hope inner conflict suicide
interpersonal loss
and significant inner turmoil there was
really nothing particularly outstanding
there's no question michael's depressed
just though there's no dispute in my
opinion anyhow
of that
did you also give him a projective test
well that was a projective test i gave
him another one called the projective
figure drawings this is a very simple
test you just ask people to draw a
picture of a house a tree a person a
person of the opposite sex and the worst
thing you could think of
usually you get nothing
not much like in this case you really
don't get
much of anything
and what do you mean by that well
nothing really significant for example
so you ask a person to draw a picture of
a house because a house is very
important to people that's where you
live if you ever drove past a home
that you're um that you grew up in your
parents sold it and new people lived
here you get a funny feeling because
your ego boundaries extend beyond you to
your house so it's important tree person
opposite sex and worst thing you think
of usually you get not much but
sometimes you do
and i i gave the i don't know if what
would be an example of a significant
drawing
well i i gave you some drawings that
i've included in a chapter that i wrote
and i have a lot of these in my book of
dismembered people exposed genitals uh
you know violence and this sort of thing
those are significant no we didn't have
i didn't have that here you interpret it
at a level of face validity um
and
most competent people
do that
um now in dr assan's report he refers to
referred to a number of people
which i thought was quite interesting
because a number of the people they
referred to as experts i not only know
these people i've worked with them about
four of them wrote forwards to my book
and he referred one of my books he
referred to reed malloy who is a very
prominent person and he wrote a forward
to one of my books wrote a chapter and
another book and i wrote a chapter one
of his but i gave you an article i don't
know if this came out where he shows a
picture
a
a figure drawing that's very
illustrative which he put in an article
that he published so you know to say
that this isn't done is just incorrect
now doctor i want to ask you about your
particular uh diagnosis or conclusions
in this case and you had already
mentioned early on
the dsm right you mentioned that there
are different
editions uh over the course of time can
you just explain to the jury uh in your
own words what the significance of the
dsm is to your field well the the
diagnostic and statistical manual of
mental disorders is really the manual
that lays out the diagnostic criteria
for all of the diagnoses and they go
through different revisions the dsm-5 i
think was 2013 is the latest revision
but there'll be another one in a couple
years why because research comes in you
understand things more it's developing
it's evolving and so uh it changes it's
been around dsm-1 was published in 1952
and this is the way you make a diagnosis
you use the criteria delineated and the
dsm now when i make a diagnosis in a
forensic case i do it with the manual
open
because who can memorize this nobody can
memorize this manual how are you going
to know
and so i do with the manual open and i
remember distinctly i said to michael
because sometimes people wonder what are
you bringing this big book out for i
said
i said i don't want to make a mistake
and i simply just going through all of
the criteria and evaluated him
with all the all the criteria all the
diagnoses that were raised in this case
you indicated that the dsm-5 is the
fifth edition
over the course of time what's your
understanding of how or the process that
goes into a new edition uh coming out oh
over the course of let's say 10 15 years
research is published and the the the
dsm folks will put together a committee
on each different diagnosis they'll
brainstorm as to what the research tells
us and then they'll make modifications
to try to keep everything up to date and
you know best practices uh and so on
now you said that when you conducted
your examination of michael barisone you
were aware of dr simmering's diagnosis
yes
did you consider a number of diagnoses
in addition to what dr simmering found
yes why did you do that because other
diagnoses were raised in the case and i
wanted to do a thorough job and make
sure i considered everything
what is what is the term psychosis mean
psychosis simply means a break with
reality and it's manifested by symptoms
such as hallucinations and delusions
hallucinations are perceptual auditory
hallucination you hear voices visual
hallucinations you see things that
aren't there usually of religious
content
olfactory hallucinations you smell
horrible smells rotting flesh
um gustatory hallucinations horrible
tastes in your mouth metal
tactile hallucinations bugs crawling
under my skin those are hallucinations
delusions
are false beliefs not based in reality
so for example
if you think two and two is six
that's not a delusion that's you're
incorrect
but if you think two and two is six
because martians change the number
system that's the delusion because
there's a break with reality that's a
bizarre delusion
now there's some non-bizarre delusions
that can actually occur
uh in daily life the difference being
martians is not an occurrence in daily
life but other things are and you could
develop a delusion so let me give an
example to illustrate a non-bizarre
delusion
i know of a case of a middle-aged
guy
worked at a large company he was a
manager of like a a unit
and the company was going through some
sort of inspection or review and he
slowly developed an idea that the
administration of the company wanted
they were the company was going to fail
this reviewer inspection they were going
to blame him for it they're all plotting
now to blame him he'll lose his job
he'll never get another job and his life
will be completely destroyed
and when he said things similar to that
to his co-workers they said to him no
what are you talking about everything is
fine the the company's not going to be
uh um
fail
no one's trying to get rid of you and
his response was you don't understand
you just don't understand that's very
typical in the delusion the people in
your circle around you try to dissuade
you
of this delusional belief
in that example you just gave was there
any
initial trigger for him having that
delusion
it was insidious it was insidious as to
why that happened
but
all of that went on for an extended
period of time a couple of months he
became more and more
delusional with respect to this
conspiracy and what finally happened is
he's walking down the hall
and the head um i guess the president or
the head administrator
said to him good morning doctor good
morning doctor good morning mr bailey
and that was it because he told his
friends he always called me bob and
today he called me mr bailey see you see
the do you see the sign that's a
delusion that's a delusion that's a
non-bizarre delusion because i mean
people get fired from their jobs but
this was a break with reality
so that's essentially what a delusion is
a fixed false belief not based in
reality
now before we get to some of your uh
diagnoses doctor you indicated that you
were aware of dr simmering's diagnosis
yes and uh
you're aware that he diagnosed the
defendant with delusional desert
disorder persecutory type and depression
disorder yes
with respect to depression disorder
would that affect a person's ability to
know right from wrong
uh generally no
would that affect a person's ability to
know
and appreciate the nature and quality of
their ex no generally no but i should i
should say i disagreed with dr simmery
with with respect to his diagnosis of
depression doctor explain that yeah dr
simmering diagnosed michael as having a
persistent depressive disorder that's
essentially a chronic low-grade
depression like a characterological
depression like a person who's like this
skeptic you know a downer i disagreed i
think he had recurrent
major depressive episodes and i based it
on
a number of factors including i read the
text messages from years ago with ann
picardo his long-term therapist and it's
way more than than persistent depression
so i disagree with dr simmering with
respect to depression i think he had a
more significant
area of depression intermittently or
recurrently
with respect to the diagnosis of
delusional disorder
are you aware of the delusion that dr
simmering identified
i'm not exactly sure of the delusion dr
simmering identified i
i mean he said it a couple different
ways it's not a hundred percent clear
he
all these texts met mes texts not text
messages facebook postings that lauren
put on the internet
dr simmering asked him essentially uh
what do you think of those and he said
they were harassing and annoying and dr
simran in his report said i disagree
with him they were coded messages where
he thought lauren was going to kill him
or so i think i i think that that that's
what he said but there was no
from when i read his report there was no
real clear delineation of what exactly
this delusion was
but um
anyway that's but there's no basis for
that at all well did you find any
evidence of delusions based on your
examination of michael bears no i found
i found no evidence of this at all and
here's what's important with respect to
a delusion this may have got
lost in the translation here
a delusion is not a fear if you're
frightened if you're terrified that is
not a delusion that's an emotional state
a delusion is a false belief not based
in reality and those in your circle try
to dissuade you of it like i mentioned
with the guy with the company
in this particular case
the people in his circle whether it was
mary haskins and or ruth cox they agreed
with him about lauren's dangerousness
if you listen to um mary haskins
interview with the police
you don't have to go beyond five minutes
she sits down she tells her what her
name is and where she's from and the
first thing she said is we're terrified
for our lives
is mary haskins delusional too
and at the end of mary haskins um
statement to the police you have to
listen to the very end because it's
about an hour or nothing she's just
sitting there in a room at the very end
she said um i don't know where i'm going
to stay tonight i can't stay at the farm
because lauren's father is going to come
and kill me
is that a delusion she's now delusional
look what ruth cox said ruth cox said
multiple times lauren is dangerous
lauren's gonna not give up until she
gets what she wants
lauren is gonna said to michael lauren's
gonna set you up for sexual assault
because she knows it's not defensible
get her out of here she's dangerous ruth
cox is also dangerous you mean
everybody's delusional there
nobody's delusional there are they
frightened yes but that is not a
delusion that's not a break with reality
now
did you ask uh
michael barissone about the pressure
that he was feeling
with respect to mr goodwin and ms
canorack being at the property
yes i mean there was a long-standing
conflict there they had there was a con
there was an interpersonal conflict
between michael and and lauren
right from the beginning when they were
florida keep in mind they met in florida
lauren came from from
north carolina they met in florida there
was interpersonal problems in florida
they went to new jersey more
interpersonal problems they went back to
florida more interpersonal problems at
this point if you're so delusional that
a person's gonna gonna kill you why do
you let him back to new jersey
they're down at that's a perfect break
time you're down in florida we're done
we're not doing any more training take
your horses put them in north carolina
but we're our training is over you
graduated or something like that why let
him back
he told me why he led him back he said
he needed the money he said
i was in under financial pressure um he
had a divorce going on he
you know he said
you have difficult clients everybody has
difficult clients you have to learn to
deal with it and and and so on
so he led him back so he wasn't that he
wasn't that frightened of her he wasn't
that terrified of her if you let her
back
did you ask him uh about the social
media posts
yes
and
did you review a number of those posts
yourself i reviewed all of the social
media posts
how did he characterize the posts when
you interviewed
well he told dr sumeria they're annoying
and harassing
and that their doctor siri thought they
were
coded messages he thought that the
manifesto was killing the king was him
and mary haskins was the queen and there
was this
all this conflict between them and
lauren's very i mean i don't i never met
lauren i know anything about lauren but
just to read these books she's obviously
very bright and very creative and um
she's writing all these things out in
symbolism and that's how he interpreted
it
i can see how he interpreted that that's
nothing distorted about it i see how he
interpret that i think it's very
reasonable interpretation
now moving ahead to uh closer in time to
the date of the shooting
did you ask michael barissone about when
he first obtained ruth cox's gun
um yes but i have to refer to my report
somewhere because i'm not it's on page
47.
okay hold on for a second
yes um
yes i asked him
what did he tell you about ruth cox has
done well
ruth said
in her statement that michael asked to
see her gun several days before the
shooting
and i asked him about that he said i
didn't ask to see your gun
and um he explained that ruth cox came
there on august 2nd and uh he he michael
knew she traveled with a gun
and he felt it wasn't safe in the car
with lauren there
and um so ruth
gave me the gun and it went into safe
that that's what he told me
what's the significance uh if that
answer is accurate what's the
significance of that answer well the
significance is he had the gun and
that's the gun that was used in the
shooting
does it show anything with respect to
the nature and quality of his actions
does it show with naked equality of
actions with respect to what
does it show anything with respect to
whether he appreciates or knows the
nature and quality of his eye well you
know certainly knows the nature and
quality of his acts what a gun is put it
in put it in the safe of course
absolutely and
also the gun was in a case and the
ammunition was not loaded
dr ruth said that and michael said that
did you ask him about the when the town
came to the property
um
i believe that's on page 48 of your
report doctor
uh yes
um
i asked about i mean the fire safety
complaint is that what you're referring
to yes i asked him about that
and he said we had a house our home was
under construction minor issues and uh
goodwin turned it in
is there anything delusional about uh
anything with respect to that no not at
all why not just isn't it's all reality
based the goodwin did turn it in the guy
came they condemned part of the um
residence and that was it it all it all
actually happened this is not in his
mind this happened
now are there different types of
delusional disorder according to the dsm
yes
can a person with delusions know the
difference between right and wrong
depends on the case
can a person with delusions know the
nature and quality of their actions
usually yes
now moving on dr uh
and in the event i hadn't asked you this
just so i make sure i don't forget are
any diagnoses that you rendered within a
reasonable degree of psychological
certainty
all of them that i rendered
now you already told us about your
diagnosis for depression
uh yes did you render a diagnosis
related to personality disorder
yes could you give me a page number
council page 64. 64. yes i did what is
personality disorder personality
disorder is everybody has a personality
and personality disorder is when the
traits are characteristic in one way
it's it's simple as that
um
i looked at him i i believe he has a
personality disorder um and i found that
the two traits that are most
characteristic of him are
obsessive-compulsive traits with the
preoccupation for detail order
organization and control devotion to
work inflexibility with respect to
morality and ethics and reluctance to
delegate to others i got this right this
is from the manual i'm not just making
that up i went right through the
criteria in the dsm and he meets the
criteria for that obsessive compulsive
personality again it's not bad it's just
characterizing uh
the way he is a lot of successful people
have obsessive compulsive traits and i
also found deep feelings of inadequacy
i mean if you look at at this case in
its entirety inadequacy and low
self-esteem always emerges it comes out
it was certainly in and picardo's um
text messages and notes he said uh
you know and even in a text to mary
haskins he said i know i'm repulsive to
you as a man
um and when i questioned him directly he
showed feelings of inadequacy as well so
i think the traits that best
characterize michael are obsessive
compulsive traits and inadequate traits
with respect to the personality disorder
diagnosis would that have affected his
ability to know right from wrong on the
day of the shooting no not at all would
it have affected his ability to know or
appreciate the nature and quality of his
actions no not at all
the last questions i'm going to ask you
about doctor you had referenced earlier
malingered amnesia yes and i know you
talked about this in your report on
pages 66 and 67 right can you remind us
what malignant amnesia is
okay well malingering is simply faking
an illness now the dsm is very it's very
important because what they say is and
and i'll refer to this on page 66 of my
report
the essential feature of malingering is
the intentional production of false
symptoms like memory loss
motivated by external incentives such as
this is
from the dsm evading criminal
prosecution
and the dsm also notes that malingering
should be strongly suspected not just
suspected i think that's possibly the
only place in the manual where they use
the word strongly suspected not consider
it think about it take a look at it no
strongly suspected if you have some of
these factors
the individual is referred by an
attorney criminal charges are pending a
marked discrepancy between the
individuals claimed disability
and objective findings and observations
lack of cooperation in the evaluation
that didn't apply and in presence of
anti-social personality that didn't
apply but his uh claim disability is
uh he claimed that he doesn't have
memory only for the criminal behavior
only for the cr his memory for
everything else is excellent are you
kidding day by day in some cases hour by
hour as to what happened
so
you know i considered first whether this
is dis
dissociative amnesia i just didn't jump
to a conclusion this is malignant
amnesia but i will say malignant amnesia
is very common in criminal cases
dissociative amnesia means means you
forget something and that can occur in a
trauma so i consider that um
why didn't you diagnose that because i
don't think it's correct i think that
this is malignant amnesia
for the reasons that i that i that i
just said you see
if you remember you have good memory
like he does
and the only thing you forget is
criminal conduct that's a red flag
because there's no memory disorder or
neurocognitive cognitive disorder that
is selective just for criminal conduct
so what does he not remember
getting the gun loading the gun driving
to where lauren was
initially hiding the gun under his shirt
asking for a goodwin to get lauren
lauren comes out he said to her are we
going to resolve this or do we go to war
and then he shot her twice
and then he has no memory for anything
else until he said he wakes up at the
hospital with a big light on him and
people are touching his
you know his arm and his uh
head injury
but there's something very odd about
that first of all the only thing you
don't remember is the criminal behavior
why is that
why isn't every if it's a trauma why
isn't everything blocked out also when
you go to the hospital
now just think you you you go to a
hospital you don't have any remember a
memory of anything you wake up in a
hustle with a big light on you and the
staff are are touching you the first
thing you say is where the hell am i
well what's going on here why am i here
he didn't say that he didn't say that at
all
and they asked him
what happened he said i don't remember
but what about the supposed delusion
that she was going to kill him that he
he didn't if he doesn't remember
getting the gun and shooting her
did he forget that he thought she was
going to kill him really he had so the
memory is not just for the criminal back
it's also for the supposed delusion well
why don't you say
i i i don't know i don't remember
anything but i know some woman's trying
to kill me that didn't happen that
didn't happen at all
doctor is there any difference between
malignant amnesia and feigned amnesia
it's basically the same
judgment
sure
doctor was this was this shooting
difficult for you to understand shooting
is not difficult to understand it's a
very easy to understand case
judge i have no further questions at
this time all right close examination
dr rob you currently have another case
with the morris county prosecutor's
office that you're uh
consulting on correct correct
now
in this particular case
you indicated that you spent a total of
13 hours
13.25 hours with regards to your contact
with my client correct yes
and how much of that 13 hours
was done
with testing
probably the first hour or two maybe
so you did about an hour or two of tech
testing
uh with regards to your evaluation
correct about that i mean you were there
i didn't i didn't time it but you were
there maybe you timed it
now
the rest of the time
you basically
let michael
talk
about this incident correct well that's
probably not a completely accurate
description of what i did i i let him
talk but it was response to my questions
so it wasn't just a free flow tell me
what you think i had a lot of pointed
questions okay now um
the testing that you did
uh would you agree that uh
you did
the short version of a number of tests i
did the abbreviated version of
the wechsler
intelligence test and i did the standard
first 370 basic questions for the mmpi
now how many questions did you give for
the mmpi 370. and how many possible
questions
could you have given
well could i have given i would have had
to i would have to interpret this test
very differently that's about i don't
even know maybe 500 i don't even know
i don't know the exact number because i
don't give the complete version i give
the version that i give
now
in your discussions with
with michael
you indicated in your report that the
the problems the conflict with lauren
cataract started in
florida
in
2019 correct it was 2018 but i could be
i could be wrong
okay
if you refer to page four
of your report
the fifth line down
is in effect you indicated on around may
of 2019
they returned to new jersey and then
later on mentioned that the conflict
between the parties
seemed to have begun in florida the
conflict began in florida i believe it
was 2018. if you look on page three in
the bottom
um she was training in in north carolina
then lauren attended uh the florida
horse facility in the winter of 2018.
2018
received training there two to three
months that's where conflicts began and
then april
2018.
yeah that's what i said in florida
what conflict oh interpersonal conflicts
there's interpersonal conflicts with
respect to who was going to do the
training was it michael was it um was it
justin
the interpersonal conflicts and would
you agree that in may of 2019
things started to get worse the conflict
uh grew uh more severe correct yes
so
without question
this conflict
this stress
lasted
well over one month correct definitely
now
did you discuss with michael different
uh
uh
things that he did
uh to try to protect himself and
everyone else at the facility were you
referring to something specific council
for instance like kim of hiring bugs yes
he hired bug sweep hired a uh
a private investigator to do a criminal
background check on him yes
um and he also hired an individual by
the name of larry david to sit at the
top
of the
property
in front of the stable to protect the
people inside at night correct
now
you said you reviewed all these social
media posts yes
how many of them were there
i don't know estimate thousands
tens of thousands i i i
i don't know i got big binders maybe the
prosecutor has an exact
um okay what are your binders regarding
social media posts thick binders
how many binders i don't know how many
binders i can't remember multiple
binders when you say multiple do you
have any specific recollection of how
many social media posts you
look through i don't have a specific
recollection as to how many social media
posts except that i read all of them now
with respect to the number of binders
this ask them i i have them at home but
i didn't count them i don't i don't know
the exact number
maybe
now you'll agree with me that with
regards to the test that that you gave
there are people that uh question
the validity of all of these tests
we say there are people what do you mean
by that just a
group of people that
if you want to
attack a test
there were people out there for every
single test that you gave
where people question the validity and
use of that test yes
yes i would i would answer it more
precisely i would say that's how science
progresses
people do tests people do research they
question it and then you move on
okay and and would you agree with me
that this is a a
fluid of science
things change
the way tests give or given changes the
way tests are given are changes but some
some conclusions with respect to lack of
validity are definitive and it's and
it's conclusive
now
you didn't put in your report everything
that you reviewed
i probably would not do that i never do
that i say i review the entire state's
case
and i ask for the entire state's case
how many
videotaped statements did you read i
reviewed all of them that i had how many
did you i don't remember what the exact
number is but let me think if i could
from my memory
um lauren's statement the defendant
didn't give a statement justin hardin
gave a statement ruth cox gave a
statement mary haskins gave a statement
defranco i
can't remember her name this gave a
statement who else
um
i don't know if there may have been
another one i just can't recall it
offhand those are the major players so
though defranco not that much
now
your position is that
and correct me if i'm wrong that
michael's
believes
that lauren cataract was going to kill
him
mary haskins and her children
is a rational
realistic
fear oh i didn't say it was rational and
realistic but it's not delusional it was
based on what was going on at the time
to be very very specific though council
with respect to his belief
of of lauren killing him that had
absolutely nothing to do with the
shooting because at the day of the
shooting he said nothing about that he
said are we going to resolve this or do
we go to war and then shot her there was
nothing like you think you're going to
kill me i'll kill you first or something
where you usually have in these sorts of
confrontations
and it was triggered by the child um
investigator coming
that's what triggered the whole thing it
wasn't triggered the day before by the
fire department coming it was triggered
by the by the investigator who wouldn't
be upset if he he incorrectly thought
that lauren called child protection she
didn't but that's what he thought but
but hold on council
hold on hold on just ask another
question sometimes we get a little too
far afield doctor we gotta reel it in
question answer answer counsel's
question don't deviate too much go ahead
ask another question
you're saying lauren cataract did not
call
dcpa
my understanding is that safe sport
called dccp that's right did you review
all of lauren cataract's text messages
yes
were you aware that she had
googled
judge objection
another question please
did you uh review review the social
media post where
lauren cataract talked about going to
war
i don't have a specific recollection of
that statement but i reviewed the social
media post yes
do you have a specific recollection of
uh reviewing posts where she accused him
of criminal conduct online
i don't i i know that that was there was
an act michael told me of an accusation
that she accused him of insurance fraud
and animal abuse i think and and
something else so i'm aware of that okay
but you don't have a recollection of
reviewing those times
but his review of the document isn't
really an issue mr blancas i've been
saying that for a long time now
the issue is
what's in a defendant's mind right so
his statements
or what's pertinent so you should
characterize or ask questions aimed at
that issue
did michael tell you that he thought
that
lauren cataract
was
dangerous yes
now you indicated that other people on
the farm felt the same way yes
would you agree with me that no one
felt that way to the extent that michael
barriston did well i would disagree to
the extent that mary haskins certainly
felt that because she said our life is
in danger and then she thought
additionally that lauren's father would
come kill her so that's pretty strong
and it's your
belief
that
those
beliefs of mary haskins were the
exact same
extent as what michael barrasson thought
i can't tell you i'm going to object
it's asking for state of mind of other
people yeah
based on not an interview with her but
on listening to an interview so
objection sustained
and
is it your belief that
those threats that michael barrasson
believed
had a
real rational basis for him to believe
them what threats
that she was going to kill him
mary haskins and the children this is
what he interpreted from the for post
this this interpretation was supported
by mary haskins and ruth cox
now
did michael tell you that
the reason
why he took the gun from
cox
was he believed it was unsafe to be in
the car because he was afraid lauren or
robert goodwin would break into the car
and get access to that weapon yes he
told me that and and
do you believe that he was feigning when
he told you that no i don't believe he
was fainting i think you'd no the answer
is no
now
with regards to your opinion that
michael is feigning amnesia as to not
remembering the event
would you agree with me
that during the incident
he was beaten about the head
no that was post-incident that was after
the shooting he shot lauren twice shot
at goodwin goodwin atta tackled him
punched him in the head put him in a
choke hold and whatever else he did that
was afterwards okay and that and that's
that's according to your review of the
discovery correct just so we're clear on
the record yeah yes correct
that comes from the statements of
goodwin and canara correct
yeah that was that after the shooting
yeah he didn't hit him in the head
before the shooting irrespective of
when he received that beating would you
agree
that
a an extensive beating to someone's head
could cause
amnesia possible but not selective
amnesia
now would you agree with me that within
moments after the incident when the
police and the first aid people respond
that
michael barristone had indicated
virtually to every single person that
questioned him but mr malinkas
just if there's a specific
i don't i don't like when you make a
broad statement like that all right just
ask if your recollection tied to the
evidence in the case all right go ahead
and rephrase your question please are
you aware that with regards to the
documents that were provided to you
that immediately after the incident that
every single in a person that might wait
a second
am i talking to myself
you don't characterize it every single
person
i said tie it to a specific witness
you can go through each of the witnesses
i don't mind if you're doing that but i
you can't just say everybody because i'm
not sure that was the testimony
doctor are you aware that with regards
to the first day people
that michael barrasso when asked
about the event
said he could not recall
anything concerning the event my
recollection is with the emt person he
made a statement that a person was going
to come to the farm and take my kids
away that's my recollection
and in addition to that that he had no
recollection of his specific event after
that
that's what he said to the ent people
after the shooting and before the police
came or as the police came he made
fatalistic statements uh i can't i have
it in my report but i can't recall
something like my life is over i had a
good life they took it all away
fatalistic statements those statements
indicate that he um he remembered what
happened because he didn't say what
happened what he didn't say arrest
goodwood he just attacked me
did any document that you read indicate
that when
they first arrived he was partially
conscious
yes did any document indicate to you
that he was incoherent
some did some did not did he
counsel hold on a second hold on a
second just answer his question please
all right is it the fact that within
with respect to all the medical records
they indicated that he was confused and
he had an altered mental state some
medical records said that and the police
record said something different
and didn't one police report indicate
that at one point he says is this real i
need to wake up i believe he said that
in the ambulance
you're sure about that that's my
recollection i questioned him about that
and and it's in my report with respect
to uh with respect to that um
respect to that okay
now you're aware that michael barriston
had seen ann picardo
over a 20-year period correct correct
did you ever talk to her no
i have nothing further
all right any um
you may step down thank you
all right any further witnesses on
rebuttal okay all right so the state
rest on rebuttal do you have one more
witness in server
let me see you at cyborg
ladies and gentlemen i'm going to ask
for your indulgence mr belinkus has a
what he says and the prosecutor agrees
will be a short server butter witness as
um as we refer to it
we're going to try to get it done today
because um that is going to be the last
witness we'll complete our testimony
today
council and i have some legal matters to
go over tomorrow so you're going to have
the day off from this trial tomorrow
you're going to come back monday for
summations and charge
and then deliberations will follow
thereafter all right so we're going to
have one quick witness tonight and we're
going to get it done as quick as
possible it shouldn't be too long go
ahead mr belinkus
all right uh left hand on the bible
again doctor please
please so in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony given to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth i do please state your name i
spell your last name for the record my
name is charles
hassan
all right you may have a seat doctor go
ahead mr balinkas dr hassan i'm going to
try to ask you some very
specific questions
and if you could
answer
as succinct and direct impossible
i would say sometimes
you you heard dr schlesinger testify
with regards to you scoring his test of
the mmpi correct yes
and why did you use his scores
it was an existing test i wanted
i wanted to compare his scores to my
scores and to see if there was any kind
of discrepancy okay and was there any
discrepancy well first of all um
answer yes or no please no discrepancy
okay and what did you find with regards
to your
scoring using his data
on on which test the mmpi
found the very elevated score on the
scale
remarkably elevated skill 90. a
scale 6 with a t-score of 90 which
suggests the delusional disorder
secondly i also found an elevation on a
scale that indicates
uh persecutory ideas
then i also scored other scales on there
that all point in the direction of a
delusion
okay did you hear his testimony
basically saying that that score of 90
means nothing
well not what he said judge yeah that's
not exactly what he said that he didn't
agree with your interpretation of that
90 score did you hear did you testify
yes i heard that and what's your
response to that i think that uh he
should be
uh he should be more familiar with the
literature on that test it's now 500
questions 567
and as i
indicated earlier today
the particular person who
i referenced
james
butcher he said that you should look up
the
references in order to understand that
and i indicated the things from
nichols david nichols but basically i
can
totally
defend any position that a score of uh
so elevated score on scale sex is
indicative of a delusional disorder
right now with regards to his testimony
concerning the rorschach you heard that
correct may just add something this is
very important in the book that was
shown to me yesterday by butcher
butcher said under no circumstances
should you play around with hand scoring
the test because it's too vulnerable to
um make errors that was the reason i ran
through the test a
second time rather than use his scores i
compared it
um okay let's move to the rorschach okay
okay with regards to the rorschach
what if any problems did you identify
with regards to his administration of
that test well i don't know i don't
first of all he used a non-standard
approach which is remarkable to me he
did not indicate where the percepts were
located you have to open up the book to
find out where it's located he eyeballed
the data in my opinion
that is a violation of
being able to analyze tests in terms of
being reliable and valid
okay now with regards to the t-a-t
basically the t-80 eyeball the data
um
that test uh
does not have any error scores in there
there's no validity
reliability and the elephant in the room
that i saw
was the fact that on two of the cards
there were weapons in there one was a
rifle and one was a handgun it looked
like and
mr barristone did not discuss that and
what does that mean to you well i mean
if you you accept the projective
hypothesis
that apparently uh dr schlesinger buys
into you ask yourself why did the person
ignore that is it part of a dissociation
where you look at the environment and
you see a stimulus you don't see a
stimulus because it's so stressful to
you
also
i'll try to keep it simple stupid
also
there was very few responses on that
test
um there was just 14 responses also just
to
have everyone know
uh on on the r pass
by meijer and the cs
trust me
those international norms are not
considered
valid i mean there's questions about it
there's a very low sample size on the
international laws laws and also on the
extra about 600 plus people on that
uh
the people they studied on the int
international
okay
as far as the http test that he talked
about what
what's your
opinion as to how he did that a joke
it's eyeballing data anyone could come
up with an an opinion on that there's no
validity there okay doctor he says he
performed tests for about an hour to two
hours how long did you test michael
barrasso how many hours
i'd say maybe seven hours
and also to score
the rorschach
you're talking about two two and a half
hours
that's a highly in a difficult test to
score
all the data on the rpas group
comes from exempt
the external system was incorporated
into the r-pass system i don't know if
uh he is aware of that okay now finally
with regards to his comments concerning
you
administering the pai test
and him reading those things with the
you know warning sign on the top of the
page
what does that mean and how
did you interpret that simply i don't
think he knows the literature on terms
of
validity testing he does not know
uh the literature from richard rogers i
use richard rogers cut scores
richard rogers and his group took into
account standard error of the
measurement if you give a test
for example
uh well okay let's go on
if you want me to
stop
the uh bender gestalt test bender stall
test is a joke in this kind of a case
bending stool test has
um false negatives that means i could be
brain damaged and do perfectly well on
that test
that's not a um an adequate test for
organicity how about the washi tape well
that's a joke too i'm sorry to say the
wassi test and the wechsler test you
know what they have in common the name
wexler
it is known
that the
wassi castle will typically elevate
scores that's why his scores are higher
than my scores that's one of the factors
but that's known you should never give
the wassi test if you're looking to give
a a complete honest
evaluation
nothing for everybody what
cross-examination non-judgment all right
you may step down thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen thank you
for your patience
you've heard all the testimony in this
case you don't have any other uh sir
rebuttal witnesses do you mr belinkus no
all right
you've heard all the testimony in this
case the next step will be
summations of counsel
and the charge by the court
we're not going to do that tomorrow for
a number of reasons number one
council and i have to review the charge
to make sure it's appropriate
and there are some legal issues that we
have to go over with regard to the
charge
and
the second reason is i don't want to
give you this case on a friday afternoon
late it's been two weeks of testimony
we're on schedule actually
um i i think we're doing better than
originally thought by council
so
i'd rather have summations monday when
everyone's fresh
i'll give you the charge you can have
the case monday and then tuesday and
however long you need next week
so we're going to
break for today i'll meet with council
tomorrow to go over to charge we'll get
that finalized and we'll return monday
morning fresh nine o'clock as always for
summations and the charge all right it's
important now you've heard all the
testimony so please don't discuss the
case with anyone
and you'll have the case for
deliberation very shortly thank you all
we'll see you monday morning same time
[Music]
off the wrapper
you